foreign
struggling with how do I tell our
six-year-old I want you to keep this
equation in your mind a plus b equals me
it's it's a it's a bomb going off inside
of it right because everything she knows
is going to be different
what up
it's John with the Dr John deloney show
I hope you're doing super good super
good that's not a dump I'm gonna I'm
gonna start over what up I hope you're
doing great hope your life is good hope
you are navigating the wild Economic
Times and your family's good and if it's
not that's what we're here for to walk
alongside you and uh if you want to be
on this show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 the greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting
podcast in a history of
again probably not true one eight four
four six nine three three two nine one
or go to John deloney.com ask let's get
right to it because I may have got some
feedback that I talked too much let's go
to Kristen in San Diego what's up
Christian
foreign
good morning oh it is before time began
out in California thanks for getting up
so early with me
yeah I'm really excited
excited since day one and I had listened
to every podcast that would make it a
priority in life to listen to you so you
are so awesome
well thank you so much thank you thank
you thank you thank you so what's up
well just to jump right in and try to
stay level and not to get too emotional
but it's your child's but how do you not
um
foreign
a few weeks ago my husband came to me
and said that he wants a divorce and I'm
really struggling with how do I tell our
six-year-old
oh six-year-old yikes all across the
board oh man
oh
what happened
you know I think go far back and and
really have some truth with myself and
say
did I ignore some real core values when
I picked a spouse with a young and
looking for the son and he was fun
eating attention and you know you
overlooked some really like I said like
the core values because hey he makes me
feel so good maybe he's not being as
nice to others as teachers that he
should be good or maybe I don't like the
choices that he made with that I
wouldn't do that but you know you make
excuses and
but recently uh hey Kristen talk
directly into your phone for me
okay can you hear me yeah much better
much better okay recently he's became
real disconnected he would lay on the
couch
interact with us and
um
we've never had the relationship where
he can effectively discuss problems it's
always like a shutdown it's kind of she
doesn't want to talk about it and I kind
of have to work on eggshells and conform
to just values and his ones and and you
know I can I can go back and I think
it's so mean I'm still really evaluating
the relationship and all the things
it went wrong and I think overall I
think I I did choose a poor spouse and
he loves her she's just hold on hold on
Kristen we can choose I mean
I I I I don't think the emphasis is so
much on Choice as much as
two adults acting like adults and
choosing as we go to be in good
relationship with one another and it
sounds like choice or not you made the
choice and he has chosen over time and
you may or may not have participated in
it but if chosen to not invest in this
relationship is that is that fair
very fair okay and so is he seeing
somebody else is he cheating on you is
he saying like I mean does it I guess
he's saying I'm not going to cheat on
you anymore because I don't want to be
married to you anymore why is he
deciding now to leave
I think he's a very negative person I
think he makes rash decisions I think he
has like grandiose ideas he may have
some depression
I don't fully know
um he's always made me feel kind of
disposable okay and
um I'm not extremely shocked okay
is there a a tiny part of you that
is kind of like yes
okay
all right good
um
like opened up the shades and I'm just
like
Kristen what have you been doing all
these years and I'm just like feeling
some freedom and like okay I need help
with myself why
I let the relationship not at least the
way it did and that's you know things
that I'll need to work on and I just
kept my whole Consignment is for my
daughter but for myself selfishly like
I'm excited okay that that I mean that's
um that's good to know because that
directs how how we're going to talk to
her
um
foreign
so you have one six-year-old is he the
father of her
uh we actually adopted her from birth we
were in the delivery room so yes she is
all
we are all she knows okay
um
and you only have one
yes okay so when you're talking about a
six-year-old I want you to keep this
equation in your mind a plus b equals me
okay and I got that from an
extraordinary child psychologist and it
stuck with me it's just a an important
reminder here's what that means
how Mom feels and how dad feels doesn't
really matter all the reasons why are
not going to compete with the
six-year-old
I had one friend who's a a child
psychologist who said
she remembers very clearly when she was
10 and her parents totally were getting
divorced and her first question was can
we still go to Arby's
okay and so it's gonna be very concrete
at the same time her body's it's a it's
a bomb going off inside of her right
because everything she knows is going to
be different even though we sometimes
use bombs to get rid of old buildings
right and to excavate sites doesn't mean
that over time this isn't going to be
the best thing and the right thing your
your responsing
um I'm married to someone who treats me
less than who has stepped out of this
marriage a long time ago who makes it
makes us all right so it's going to be a
good thing over time
um but it's going to be an explosive
moment okay so don't be surprised if
everything is the questions that come
are about her that's developmentally
appropriate it should be if you're
having this conversation with a 17 year
old it's a totally different track okay
um here's the two things she's going to
want to know
what did she do to make this happen
and is she gonna be safe meaning what
happens next
okay okay
so here's a couple of rules of thumb
one to two minutes per year
so this conversation this first one will
be 10 to 12 minutes and that's about it
okay
okay not a lot of explanations not a lot
of oh this is and that's and and then
Mommy none of that
um it will be quick and if you can
you've heard me say this a lot um kids
we all do but kids especially absorb
power differentials so if you can get
down on her level look her in the eyes
okay this works way way better if your
husband acts like a mature adult and
will be in there with you is that
possible
yes he will he will really yes yeah he
he is with her
love
I know that we'll do it together the
conversations we've had is he's been
involved he's having ideas how to tell
her so okay
um so we're gonna sit down together on
the floor with her okay and we're going
to let her know this is a very serious
Mom and Dad conversation and the
conversation we'll start with Mom and
Daddy love you we will always love you
and Mom and Daddy will never leave you
and
um and
mommy and daddy have made a grown-up
decision that we are going to get
divorced
so we are taking full even if you're
thinking inside I actually don't want to
be getting divorced now
we are going to take full ownership of
this thing and begin planting seeds now
they're going to bloom 10 years from now
15 years from now 20 years from now that
this is not her fault okay
so we're going to plant those seeds now
mommy and daddy made a grown-up decision
and we are going we are going to get
divorced so that means you're going to
spend one week at Mommy's house and
you're gonna spend one week at Daddy's
house and then here's what I'm talking
about the concrete you're gonna have a
toothbrush at Mommy's house and you're
gonna have a toothbrush at Daddy's house
and you're gonna have friends at Mom's
house and friends at Daddy's house and
if you know the information like you're
gonna stay in this school and you're
going to we're still going to have
morning breakfast on Thursdays or
whatever the thing is
some really concrete really quick things
okay
and then check in with her how does this
feel in your body
how does this feel tell me the words
that are coming to your heart she may
talk a lot well are we still gonna have
Christmas she may ask something like
that she will probably ask why
why because it doesn't make any sense to
a kid that why would adults voluntarily
choose misery right why would you
voluntarily choose to have to split up
everything and move all that right so it
doesn't make sense
um and that's okay the answer is to why
is this is not your fault and we both
really love you and we will never leave
you
okay we're not going to get into with a
six-year-old we're not going to get into
well Daddy has been this and Mom we are
made we made a grown-up decision
that this is best for us
okay and just know that any of your
explanations are not going to register
with a six-year-old outside of we're
making adult decisions okay
okay
um
here's another hard one and this is a
conversation you can have with him and
you can tell him I said this directly to
your husband
uh my friend Dr Steve Jennings
um he works he's an act he's an expert
working with men but he's worked with
families for years
here's what he tells his clients and I
love it
he says
I tell a client that right before you're
about to say something negative about
your spouse who you just got divorced
with
I want you to find your kid and I want
you to punch him in the stomach as hard
as you can
my gosh okay
and then go ahead and tell them what
you're going to tell them about their
dad or about their mom
that's the level of violence both
physiologically and cognitive a kid
absorbs when they hear that Dad is the
worst or your dad's doing this or Mom
just kicked me out or I don't right
here's why and you've heard me say this
before on the show and I'll say it again
kids know that half of me is him and
half of me is her
and when we tell them and especially an
adoptive situation we opted into this
right and so this kid's gonna have even
more wait right so this is going to be a
dicey situation for a while with this
youngster
they need to know I'm not talking bad
about dead even though you might think
he is the biggest scumbag ever he's
going to have he's gonna pop up in two
weeks with some new girlfriend or
whatever and you're gonna think I knew
it
that can't filter to her that's got to
be you with your adult friends your
adult counselors your adult grown-ups in
your life who are walking light doing
life with you is that you see what I'm
saying
yeah and he your husband can not
cannot
avoid a hard conversation with her
at the expense of you and what I mean by
that is he cannot say
well your mom just man she was tough to
be married to so I had to go no he has
to take ownership of his actions I told
your mother that I no longer want to be
married to her
but even though I'm not your mom's
husband I will always be your daddy
okay
and we're gonna always loot back after
that 10 or 12 15 minute talk
um we're gonna one or two of y'all are
gonna take her somewhere
because now she's going to want to test
it because y'all said y'all were going
to stay together forever and y'all are
breaking up but you're telling me you're
going to love me forever maybe right and
now the now now the next 5 10 15 20
years of testing begins
can I push you far enough that you're
gonna actually walk away from me too and
the answer to that has to be no both of
you right
okay
um so that means after that we're gonna
go to ice cream get ice cream
we're gonna go to the park
um daddy's gonna take you to go get a
hamburger
and we're gonna go do something we're
not just gonna drop that bomb in 12
minutes and then walk out and leave the
six-year-old in her room by herself
she's gonna and we're not gonna talk a
lot about it in the car either we'll
answer all of her questions age
appropriately but we're not gonna bring
it up we're not going to go over we're
not gonna go over
um
we're gonna show her love by connection
and attention we're gonna put our phones
away and we are just gonna go sit at a
table and in fact hang on the line I'm
gonna send you all of the questions for
humans cards I have for kids and parents
and teens and every all of those
um and that'll give you something you
can do while you're out getting ice
cream together or something okay that
was gonna be my next question is if you
had any resources or advice on something
to read so I just thank you so much
actually I'm gonna do this this is a
strange thing hold on
I'm pulling up um something I never do
um but I'm pulling my phone out here my
my friend Dr Jennings sent me these two
books
um one is called my two homes by
um Alejandro poso Stevenson
um it's called my two homes and there's
another book called two homes filled
with love by Steve Herman and she
recommended this on those two books as
great resources I'll link to them in the
show notes I've never read them I've
never opened them but she has this
conversation all the time and she says
they are excellent books just to read to
especially to a six-year-old right oh
okay
um and we'll link to in the show notes
and you can just pick them up on Amazon
and uh but I I think having some direct
connecting connection time and here's
one last final thing
it is okay to tell her that I'm very
very sad
and daddy's very very sad
it's okay to say we had expected to be
married forever and we've made grown-up
decisions to not be married for not be
married anymore
but your daughter's gonna feel very very
sad
mainly because she doesn't understand
mainly because she's all the abandonment
all the stuff right
um
and if she knows Mom feels sad and dad
feels sad then she's going to feel not
crazy
and so you being honest about how you
feel when it comes to grief
um is going to be important and by the
way my guess is y'all's marriage has
been a mess for a while is that fair
oh absolutely yeah
um I'm I'm kind of hit a lot of it and
made the best of it and I think I was
honest with my stuff about a year ago
and I said this is not who I would
choose this isn't the relationship I
would choose and knowing his inability
to even have
productive conversations he would never
work on it so I kind of you know this
this situation I'm in and I'm going to
write it out for my daughter I'm almost
thankful that she that he
did the hard thing and decided you know
came to me and said no like this
marriage is over about let's rip the bit
off now make no mistake I I have yet to
see any sort of data or research that
would suggest that
had you sat with him and said hey we are
intentionally choosing a life of misery
together
let's intentionally choose something
else
and that means
um we're gonna have to learn new skills
right and he said you're right I'm I'm
done choosing misery choosing immaturity
so I'm going to choose maturity which
doesn't mean I'm gonna suddenly become a
great communicator overnight but that
means I'm going to commit to learn how
to be like that Arc would have been much
better for everybody but it didn't
happen yeah right it didn't happen so
now we're dealing with reality and your
husband says he's walking out on y'all
and so you can breathe for the first
time in a long time there will be
healing in the house in the home they'll
be healing in your daughter's heart no
question about it
um you and your husband are gonna have
to choose and maybe this is the
conversation you have with him you and I
have both chosen over the last six seven
eight nine years however long we've been
married
to not communicate well
we have chosen to be distant from one
another we cannot do that moving forward
with our child
we're going to have to choose to talk
we're gonna have to choose to be open
with one another when I say I don't want
her dating and you say I do want her
dating we're gonna have to sit down like
adults and have that conversation and
not just fire texts off back at each
other right you see what I'm saying
you're gonna have to have a level of
attentionality with your divorced
relationship than you did with your
married relationship right which sounds
crazy because we could have just done
this five years ago we didn't so here we
are okay to all you listening
um to this
hear where this goes
right here where this goes to the men
listening to this or watching this
don't choose misery and that doesn't
mean leave
that means sit down across the table
or sit down on a couch next to the
person you said you love that you said
you're gonna live forever that you
either made kids with made humans with
or you adopted you created you created a
family unit
say I'm done choosing misery
will you be done choosing misery too can
we choose something way better than this
and I'm gonna have to learn some new
skills you're gonna have to learn some
new skills would you learn those with me
I promise I'll go first
and wives you you hear the end here a
woman who said I wouldn't have picked
him and now I'm just going to cash out
the rest of my life
I'm just gonna crawl under this blanket
and just stay here until this thing's
over
you get one shot you get one tiny little
life don't live like that
the institution of marriage just gets a
bad rap and these
if you will put the work in and the
work's hard it is hard it is hard and
it's new and it's shameful and it's
embarrassing it's all it's frustrating
it's all those things
but I promise you compulsive Spenders
and you're married to somebody who's
like why you keep running this into the
ground financially compulsive cheaters
why what is it about you that you think
you're gonna find out there
compulsive just sitting on the couch
grabbing five beers after work and
saying I'm out I'm out why
why choose that life
choose something different
and if you're married choose to do it
together
choose to do it together these kids they
need us
we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spitting
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right hey we are back um just a
minute ago somebody reached out to me on
the internets on Instagram and asked if
I would send if she asked me if I send
her husband uh to slide into his DMS and
wish him a happy 30th birthday and I was
like Ah that's that's how the kids do it
these days I'll just call him like an
old man and so uh she said no way so she
gave me a cell number let's call him
thank you foreign
hey Josh
hey
this is John deloney from the John
deloney show what are you doing
is this for real
oh man you're having a really weird
dream right now what are you doing where
are you
we are at Opry Mills right now
right down the street from us yeah
exactly are you just hanging out in
Nashville
uh yeah we we were up here for the day
uh just just to hang out my wife's doing
a party for us uh tonight or for for me
and it's uh man she's yeah she's going
all out for me today she hey she's been
all out she paid me ten thousand dollars
to call you just now just kidding she
didn't she didn't at all she didn't know
hey man happy 30th birthday brother
hey thank you so much man and thanks for
being on our weird little gang here uh
oh man on our show man I love it oh yeah
man I appreciate all you've done hey
we'll I'll be here all day and I've got
another radio show after this if you
want to come down and come down to this
to the studios and see us that'd be
great man
oh dude I might take you up on that what
else are you doing today I'm just
kidding your wife's planned this cool
birthday hey man happy birthday uh stay
in school don't do drugs all that stuff
is that cool okay yeah absolutely all
right brother hey take care make good
choices today
um all right there we go way way to go
Josh happy birthday all right let's go
to
um oh let's just stay here let's go to
AJ in uh Nashville what's up AJ
hey uh thanks for taking my call you got
it brother what's up
um I wrote my question down so I didn't
uh you know flower on too much so I
should do that robotic that's why I
should do that I should start running my
yes okay good job yes all right what's
up all right um so I have a question
about getting married and before I get
married how
uh I can best prepare myself for the
relationship with my girlfriend's
younger sister
so it's a really long story I was gonna
say this this sounds Jerry springery no
take me to it
so long story short she has custody of
her teenage sister
okay
um and I'm 25
and uh her younger sister is about to
turn 16 so there's not a huge gap
between us
okay
um so I'm I'm just kind of how old is
your fiancee
she's about to turn dirty okay
um
and so our
her parents just out of the picture
um yeah yeah pretty much her dad's
around but he is not uh eligible for
custody I guess there's a way to put
that wow he's got he's a mess huh
yeah it's a it's a whole mess okay
um so tell me what your concerns are
um
I guess just uh foreign
proper boundaries between like
friendship and also being able to
support
my girlfriend and like decision making
with
uh how to help and her sister's life
sure if that makes sense yeah absolutely
uh when are you actually getting married
so
that's a thing I actually haven't
proposed to her yet so I've got myself
on a little timer here before this
episode comes out
that's coming up that's next listen
here's what would be great the moment
this episode drops have her be here at
the studio and you can propose here and
then we'll just do the wedding here too
okay all in one day and then you can be
like by the way on the way home we need
to listen to this episode they just
dropped today that'd be fantastic
um so I'll I'll have to I'll have to
look into my plans and see if that's uh
better than what I already have going on
will she that might be better man yes I
don't know that's like my prom date when
I asked her to prom she's like I don't
know let me see if there's some other
other people that might be better than
you oh I don't know I don't know if you
can tell from the how early I'm asking
this question I'm a little bit of a
planner in that way yeah you're a little
bit over dramatic so here's here's what
I would tell you
um
don't overthink this and don't
underthink this no let me say it this
way don't overthink this and don't under
plan this
okay
here's what I mean by that and I I
hopefully I just made your your planner
a little plan our heart so happy he's so
happy
um
you and your new when you when you get
engaged
you all sit down and establish the
boundaries of your new home together
okay
here's who we are going to be as a
couple
sister goes to the side for just a
moment here is who we are going to be
we're going to be people of hospitality
we're going people of character we're
going to borrow money we're not going to
borrow money we are going to both work
or but all those questions right
set up your home in fact I recommend uh
premarital counseling I think it's Wise
Wise Wise just to get with somebody
who's going to help you answer questions
that you don't even know to be asking
yet okay so
we're going to set up the boundaries of
our home and then we're going to look at
the inhabitants of our home and this is
a common mistake parents with just uh
biological kids make they Factor who
we're going to be based on the kids and
then the kids end up being the center of
the home okay so the second one is
you are not this young woman's dad
right right and you can never become a
pseudo dad and you might be the first
stable mature male adult this young
woman has ever ever met
and so you'll have a modeling
responsibility you'll have
accountability responsibility
right but you're not Dad see the
difference there
right yes and I think with a 16 year old
I would put that out right in the open I
will not your dad I will never be your
dad
but I'm 10 years ahead of you in this
crazy Life Adventure and I got some
wisdom and I will take care of you and I
will honor you and I will be there as as
whenever you need however you need and
here is the rules of this home here's
Who We Are
okay and it's much easier to have a
conversation beginning with here's who
we are not here's what we're not going
to do
okay so here's a good example of that
with a 16 year old
you can sit down and say hey we're
getting married
you haven't before but you got a
midnight curfew now
you can start there and you might as
well just declare war right
or you can say hey in this home a
Cornerstone of this family this new
family is we're going to honor our
bodies we're going to be good stewards
of our bodies and that means we're gonna
eat at home more than we eat out we are
going to go for walks as a gang we'd
love to invite you
um and we get sleep we value sleep here
that's just who we are and you got two
years before you can leave if you want
to
um but while you're here this is how we
do this and we're going to model this
okay you see the difference there what
is it one is an invitation and one is a
demand and ultimately as a parent you
always will get to demands at some point
but it's so much better to start with an
invitation
okay
um and then I think you set up
relationship
way Upstream
what I mean by that is just talk to your
wife your soon-to-be new wife or your
fiance when she comes your fiance and
have things like uh I challenge you to
a video game once a week or we have
breakfast out on the front porch just
you and her once a week or I'm gonna
develop relationship way Upstream so
that when I do have to have
accountability conversations in our home
um there's a context to them we actually
do that now I once a month we have like
a me and her hang out like I take her to
wherever I'm like hey do you want to do
something fun or you know uh
if my girlfriend's off that weekend she
does it with us but if not we we keep
our plans going and we'll we'll go to a
waterfall or you know we go to a library
or have plans together and I could like
just kind of model try not not any model
sounds weird but I just want to be
around her in like a
a positive influence way because I love
that said she hasn't had that really you
are modeling stability okay but I also
also know how deep this modeling goes
it's you picking up a piece of trash as
you walk across a parking lot
it's you tipping really really well
even when the service wasn't great
and you tell your
um this young woman
um
I'm gonna honor this woman with a great
tip
and you show up when you say you're
going to show up right you see what I'm
saying like she's absorbing everything
because she's got a her a part of her
brain that is searching for when you're
going to leave to
because that's all she knows is at some
point the men in her life pack up and
leave
or they go bananas and the court says
we're stepping in because you're not
safe together
and so you're modeling all the time
which I think is beautiful and great
once you this you all become a family
you want you all move in together and
this becomes a family unit here
um make that once a week
and it can be as simple as
um I I this is how
lame I am I take my own questions for
humans cards I did it this morning once
a week my son and I go to uh Waffle
House
and we have breakfast together and we
ask questions this morning we had a long
discussion about what do we want etched
on our Tombstone that's one of the
questions
in a million years I would not have
gotten there with my with my 12 year old
son okay but it's once a week it's a
context we talk about our gratitudes we
have little journals that I take with us
and so it's become more of a formal
thing
and it is a little eye rolly that's so
early I know and then when we get there
it's incredible and I learned more about
him doing those things so hang on the
line I'm going to send you all the
questions for humans I got okay the
whole the whole gamut and you can pick
and choose which ones those you think
would be great there's parents and teens
there are friends there's any number of
them would work for this context okay
um thank you that's awesome but I think
having some sort of tool this is just a
thing we do together we have breakfast
once a week and I think that would be
really great
yeah that would be awesome because as
much as I try to like connect and be
around her she's into much different
things than I am of course certainly
enough yes well and that's a good thing
right and you're not coming in to
shape-shift any of that stuff but you
are coming in to say here's what
stability looks like and there's not a
thing you can do that's going to push
um me and or your sister away
all right and it may be a conversation
no no not maybe it needs to be a
conversation that you have with your
soon-to-be fiance about College Planning
about job training about grades those
all those expectations as a 25 year old
you're getting launched into it not an
apparent role but in a
supportive adult role and it's just
gonna be awkward and weird and
challenging for the next few years I do
think any sort of discipline
is best done in Partnership but with
your
gonna be wife taking the lead on that
because she's got the long-term
relationship she's got custody all that
kind of stuff maybe down the road you
just you and your wife have a
conversation about you adopting this
young woman all those things are
possible but I think heading into it is
I'm not your dad
and I'm not going anywhere right and I
applaud you brother I applaud you for
already
inviting this young woman into your life
in in an organic way in a compassionate
way in a I'm going to be stable and I'm
going to show you what that looks like
that's awesome AJ thank you for loving
her and dude come down here do your
proposal just be fun it'll be awesome
hey we'll be right back
all right let's take into Moss let's go
out to Columbus Ohio and talk to
Arlington what's up Arlington
hey how much dude how are you good hey
what's your nickname what do people call
you I call it Harley Arlington dude I
like that very cool okay
all right so what's up man
hey um yeah so I'm kind of looking for
some advice
um my wife uh does a very good job of
beating herself up and I sometimes don't
know what to do in the realm of maybe
helping her get out of her head and I
don't know if I'm doing something wrong
um I think part of it comes down to I've
always been
pretty good at being like a
someone that people can come to when
life's getting rough
um I just for some reason I can't
get through that's the wrong way to work
if I can't
get to my wife the question I wrote down
is how can I help my wife
um when she gets stuck in her own head
does she have mental health Diagnostics
um so this past year so she is a
previously has been hospitalized back
when probably 20 years ago
um for anorexia
um and that a lot of this stems from
body image issues and more recently
we've been in the trying to get hormones
balanced game off of a little birth
control I'm trying to get hormones
balanced and that has just kind of
thrown a world of unknown at her that
she maybe just doesn't have the tools to
kind of handle on her own
say more about that are you saying that
as you're rebalancing hormones like
going through
hormonal rebalance is madness right the
way I've heard it described is you feel
insane because your head doesn't your
body's feelings don't match what's going
on in your head and it's just it's out
of it's It's Madness right and you're
trying to then just show up at work and
be you know kind and approachable and
it's just insane right it feels insane
absolutely
um
are y'all trying to get pregnant
um in the near future it's nothing that
like we're stressed out about right now
but it's definitely something down the
road where we we want some kids
um what made you want to what made her
want to go get her hormones checked and
rebalanced
it was just
a a woman who has sustainable hormones
that are produced by her own body and
things like things like that okay
foreign
yeah and it's um I mean her and I are
very very different
um but I'm always
quite optimistic about things and a lot
of hers is a negative uh stealth talk
and
um things like that I
I I almost after I made this call last
week was pretty tough
um this week seems to be a lot better
and it kind of just yo-yos like that um
what is what is Pretty Tough mean is she
suicidal
I took a little leaf out of your own
book and just asked her straight up
because I was I was to the point where I
didn't know I was like hey man like are
you gonna kill yourself and she's like
no I just don't know what's going on
um and so not not that far but just kind
of
grasping at straws and not really
holding on to anything is where we're at
okay
um this situation is more concerning
than a traditional someone's just
talking to himself badly okay okay so
the way I look at these generally is I'm
looking at a trend line
yeah and this there's a person here with
a history of disorder eating which tells
me there's a history of some sort of
anxiety OCD some sort of control which
may mean there's a history of some sort
of abuse or neglect am I onto something
there
um yeah I don't know if I've dug far
enough into the abuse or neglect but
everything else is spot on for sure okay
so
um
you deal it sounds like somebody who has
really been working on the symptoms
but has a body that is trying to keep
her alive
a body that thinks that it's at war with
its environment which ultimately becomes
a war with itself
and whenever I've got a person who I
care about and I love and their bodies
at war with themselves eventually the
fighting gets so exhausting and I don't
want to die I don't want to do drugs but
I need this to stop
you see what I'm saying and when I it's
like a someone on a skateboarder on a
sidewalk I'm looking at a trend in just
the few things you've mentioned to me
Tom I don't like the direction of this
trend
okay tell me I'm wrong
no I mean I'd say pretty nail it ahead
um so her and I met at work
pretty bad work environment for her so
she stepped away and now does Faking out
of our house and it's kind of become a
little bit of isolation to where it's a
ton of isolation super lonely right yes
uh and so she has done some stuff
recently and then like she is like foot
on the gas going like working for it
because she also realizes that like she
doesn't love the trajectory that she's
going okay
um I say it's more of like the rolling
the ball uphill and it kind of coming
back on top of her time after time
that's exactly right situation that's
exactly right
um
foreign
so I want you to keep this in mind and
then I'll give you a strategy that I
would use if I was in your exact seat
okay okay I want you to from this point
forward I want you to think of being
with not fixing
that's been a shift that I've really
tried to do yes you can't fix her
what you can do is help create an
environment to where she can heal with
the work that she's going to do
okay the creation of that environment
for most of us is a set of skills we
don't have
occasionally people have that and it's
amazing I didn't have it I had to go
learn it okay and so a great gift would
be I want to be the greatest husband to
you
and I want to love and support you
would you be willing to go to marriage
counseling with me so that I can learn
some new tools to love and support you
and this is you not trying to fix her
this is you inviting her into your skill
development
okay okay this is about you
yes and it's not that you're so crazy I
don't even know what to do anymore it's
not that at all it's how long have y'all
been married
just over two years okay so we're two
years in
as we think about having a family as we
think about all it's going to be a broad
this knucklehead on this podcast is
always telling us hey we get to paint a
picture of where we want to go and then
we get to live into this picture would
you be willing to go I'm just a terrible
painter would you be willing to go with
me and learn how to paint see what I'm
saying yeah and
um she is going to take this my guess is
as an anxious person as a person who's
scanning her environment 24 7 for
threats she's going to take this as my
husband's going to leave me
or she's going to take this as I'm
causing my husband to go crazy
and you're gonna have to speak to her in
the way that you know her she's your
wife in in ways that she can hear you
that no no this is about me I want to go
I want to go learn some new stuff
okay when it come you can draw
boundaries in a home
and my wife did this for me so I don't
this isn't for everybody and I can see a
way where this might be shameful so
you're gonna have to know your wife and
it may be something you you talk over
with your counselor but my wife said I
will no longer tolerate anybody talking
to my husband in negative ugly ways and
that starts with you
and that's how she couched it it wasn't
hey you need to fix your negative
self-talk it is I'm not going to allow
somebody to talk to my husband like this
okay right and so you can set up
boundaries and say I love you too much
to let anybody talk negatively about you
call you unattractive call you
overweight call you crazy call your
whatever
I'm asking you to not talk to my wife
that way
okay okay and it might be one of those
things that you call it out my wife can
she's gonna look very very similar to
Kelly except way less mean and she'll
she can look at me and I'll know like oh
yeah I just did that thing right
um and so that can be a way to lean into
that but it's a again it's a it's you
owning the boundary it's not her fixing
a problem
yes yeah yeah see what I'm saying
um
are her is her family involved or are
they part of the problem
most loving uh loving parents they are
awesome um but I think a lot of times
her mom has a lot of anxieties as well
um and I can see that kind of not
stirring the pot but
not always being the most helpful but I
would also say to her mom a lot of times
is the most helpful
um because she knows how to talk to her
sometimes a lot better than I do
um well
or she knows how to push her buttons a
lot better than you do
in some ways yes we will yes um she
needs there's going to come a moment
when that relationship is going to have
to be minimized in a dramatic fashion
okay
um that's probably best done by a
counselor unless you find yourself
between your wife and her mother who's
both the curse and has made herself the
blessing too
yeah
um and that's a hard place to find
yourself you may have to get there at
some point my hope would be that a
counselor could point out some of those
behaviors and which relationships are
feeding and nourishing her I'd also
recommend y'all start inviting people
over to your house
just go first and be weird about it and
be vulnerable about it and just say hey
we're gonna have three people over let's
just make a commitment to twice a month
let's have people over even though we
can't afford it they can all bring We'll
have cereal night whatever who cares
yeah yeah um we'll do whatever we'll get
have game night we'll do something but
we need to inject people back into our
lives because yeah that this working
from home thing
um I get it I can imagine it being
wonderful and I can also it's destroying
people when it comes to loneliness
absolutely destroying people so uh or if
she wants to y'all want to look at her
going back to an office somewhere else
um but my guess is
she's gonna have to do the work to heal
trauma that's going to allow her body to
stop just raining those alarms down on
her 24 7. so that
she can sleep and finally be at peace so
that her hormone regulation and all
these other things that we're trying to
fix on the periphery here and hormone
regulation is actually on the periphery
that's I mean you get some hormones
lined up and you're talking about life
change right but sometimes getting their
space
um and that's both for men and women
It's just tough but
we need to get that body her body to
have peace right absolutely and that's
going to start with relationships and
sit down and talk to somebody is she
seeing a counselor right now
she is yeah uh how's that going
was bouncing around to a couple
it's her yeah it's her yeah and my guess
is every work environment is always
toxic
and you may be the one guy who's gotten
through is that fair
yeah my guess is every relationship at
some point turns to come after her is
the way she feels
that is that am I right
yeah
at some point she's gonna have to look
in the mirror and absorb she's the
common denominator in all of those messy
relationships
okay and that is both a scary and
daunting
um realization
yeah
okay I hate that for y'all am I I mean
is there ever a time that she's like
this person and you're and you think I
mean come on
uh as far as like go in and like full
bore like I can't believe this person
yes
Yeah okay or if you find yourself in
fights you're like yeah and you're kind
of like I mean it's not that big a deal
you mean uh yeah yep yep okay so at some
point we're gonna have to make peace
she's got to make peace with
maybe my body's reacting to people in
ways that is not consistent with reality
and I'm gonna have to relearn how to
have peace in my life so that I can
re-enter relationship with people so
that I could actually be well
right and that's when I tell you about
that trend line man I just don't like
the trajectory here because the this
trend spins the top spins faster and
faster and faster and it gets more
Tangled Up and more complicated to
unwind
right
um and I think that's where we met and
so a lot of the
and again you may be able to speak more
into this um the body image stuff seemed
to be quite heightened
um at the gym just because of the like
external looks that people are trying to
give themselves sure um
I'm
is that something that's worked like
from my end worth trying to
move myself out of uh quit your job
what's that like just quit your job
I mean in an irresponsible like move on
so we can both get out of that
absolutely environment absolutely okay
Enviro I mean
ultimately those alarms are our body's
response to our environment
okay and when our our bodies are
detecting threats in an environment that
aren't there then we're then the the
alarm needs some tuning right
um but if I keep throwing myself back in
a toxic environment that I know is not
good for any of us then yeah
okay
um I'm in that like like you said I know
I can't fix but I might be able to
support and so I'm in between that
um
of me continuing down that line
kind of help lead to the environment
that becomes toxic
um yeah I mean here's a better way to to
frame it
um
my wife is equally a part of this job
because now people take pictures of us
at restaurants
okay and people send me direct messages
about my wife
right and by the way if people do that I
just block you instantly I just I'm I
mean I'm not gonna do that
um only my closest friends can make fun
of my wife right so I I she's a part of
this
and at any moment if she said I'm out I
cannot be a part of this
then I would be out
yep and that's a choice I've made and
that's super counter cultural because
the culture the culture is like no you
you do you and if she can't hang then
I'm not doing that she's my priority
right correct and so there there's like
I can't imagine being 80 and being like
Oh I'm so glad I remained a tick tock
sensation over that dumb marriage I had
for two that just seems insane all right
I agree yeah and so
um if you were put on Earth to help
people with their physical fitness
that's that's a conversation I believe
that my role here is to help people be a
little better off than they were before
they met me all right and I can do that
at McDonald's and I can do that on a
YouTube show and that's also why my boss
interviewed me for 18 months and my wife
came on a lot of those interviews too
because it was
I need you to have a full picture of
what you're taking on here
right so there was that's part of it but
so it's less about I don't want you to
get in a tail chasing game where you're
trying to figure out what's the next
thing you could do to make this maybe
help this because dude then you're going
to be in a mess right but you can say
there's an overall toxicity to our home
um
because of the work I do because of the
schedule I keep because of I've got to
be on my phone 24 7 saying yes to
clients and somebody canceled I got to
find another client because
um I had these dreams of making seven
figures as a personal trainer and I'm
making forty one thousand dollars a year
like all the those are the contributing
factors here right
um if my wife ever came to me and said
you're not allowed to ever help another
person ever again well that'd be a
different conversation but also she
would be my wife at this point because
that that would be Madness right we
would have had that conversation a long
time ago
but she can tell me hey I need you to
quit running around in the middle of the
night
um dealing with people who've passed
away because it's it's impacting the way
you treat the kids that's very fair that
in fact that's her that's her role in my
life and vice versa and so yeah I mean
if you can change the context I'm all
for that
don't do it thinking that that's going
to be the Hail Mary pass that's going to
heal your wife because it won't be but
it might take some of the toxicity out
of the environment and for you to even
be asking that question says hey you're
really a tuned caring husband and B
makes me think you want out anyway right
so good for you good for you but
um
she needs to go see a counselor or a
psychologist and y'all need to stick
with that for a season
um we're going to commit to seven
sessions we're going to commit to 10
sessions with this one person and we're
going to ride out the relationship into
when it gets uncomfortable we're going
to go through the discomfort and stay in
the relationship we're not going to run
from it because we run from every
uncomfortable relationship
and by the way Arley don't be surprised
at some point this I'm I'm disconnecting
from this relationship gets aimed at you
okay you're gonna have to decide I'm
gonna ride the rough rough Waters
um
she needs to go see somebody and be
consistent and I would love to see you
um Say Hey I want to learn something new
and I want you to come with me it's
awesome she's lucky to have you Harley
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own in your past change your
future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
um man whenever I need some
some poetic thinking through of an issue
one of the places I go is the Avett
Brothers I think they are some of the
greatest Poets of our time
um and Kelly found this one is it Kelly
I found this one
it's a beautiful song man so uh I'm
gonna read the whole thing stay with me
on this one it's called the divorce
separation Blues
I'm Gonna Keep on Living even though I
sometimes do fantasize about
disappearing down in the ocean blue just
to get some peace and quiet from the
Warfare inside my heart
while I've been under ear splitting fire
ever since we've been apart I'm gonna
wash the dishes pay the bills watch the
news
I got the tough education there's no
celebration I got the divorce separation
Blues
I'm Gonna Keep on waking and rising up
before the sun and lying in the dark
wide awake when everyone else is done
and sleeping in their beds so peaceful
dreaming with the love they chose
and I'll sign on the line Beneath My
Name the road is gone I can't go back
the way we came
well neither one of us really want to
hit the town we try to keep our friends
at Bay to try to keep the gossip down
some folks just want the dirt don't even
care if it's true and then again who
cares who's talking I'm worried for
myself and for you and I'll sign on the
line Beneath My Name the road is gone
and I can't go back the way we came
if your marriage is sideways right now
turn the lights on
sit down and say let's choose something
different I'm in if you are
and if somebody comes to you and says
hey let's do something different
once again say I do
we'll see you soon